how's your son
about your day well it gives daddy Vibes
you know being a single mother to a son
they want us to find
a man although he's picky Tamar
Braxton's son looks out for Mom in the
dating world you date him again well you
have to check out the show of course
fans of the singer are well aware that
she's off the market oh I'm crazy about
you Eugene and Tamar wants people to
watch her love story play out on Queen's
court
she doesn't go into her happy ending on
the Jennifer Hudson show you see a whole
different side of me yes and you know I
mean I
eventually don't want to be single
forever everybody want a fine day you
know mate and I do so you're ready for
love I'm ready but who was not so ready
at first her son Logan Tamar shares him
with ex-husband Vincent Herbert we both
got Sons yes we do and my baby don't
even like me on the phone with nothing
who you talking to I'm growing about who
I'm talking to how's your son
about your day is he funny like well it
gives daddy Vibes don't they yeah
because ultimately our children wants us
to be happy although he's picky well
that's a good thing hello he's he wants
me to be happy yeah but I'm gonna find
it in the house I gotta go outside child
well you know look I had to find Mr
Right somewhere that somewhere the
dating pool of reality TV I can meet the
happiest man in the whole world
and Mr Wright is attorney Jeremy J.R
Robinson I don't want to be your friend
I'm gonna be your husband
say more
oh my God
I'm here forever because I don't see my
life about you
I love you Tamar
and the lead will you marry me
what did he make of Mama going on a
reality show today well at first he was
not here for it really yes um and the
biggest thing about you know being a
single mother to a son they want us to
find
a man they really do he does he really
truly wanted me to find my my life
partner and you know I definitely want
to you know have a husband and I hope
that he has kids and so we can you know
I have a blended family and you know
things like that and I think that he's
attracted to that as well well how's
this for a blended family Tamar's fiance
has five kids from previous
relationships it's a natural part of
life you know choosing and finding the
person you are supposed to be with
forever and so hopefully this is a
lesson for him when he gets to be of age
you know to do some do's and don'ts what
is that dating age for you do you have
an idea yes yes at the ripe age of 37.
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you